This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In all our lives, there are moments when the ground starts to shake beneath us, when our world becomes destabilized and everything changes. Sometimes, this untethered feeling comes after we lose a job or end a relationship. Sometimes, it comes on us more gradually, with a slow realization that the life we've built isn't fulfilling us in the way we thought it would. These moments can feel disorienting, upsetting, but they can also allow us to see things in new ways. Today, we continue our Happiness 2.0 series with a look at something simple but essential
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。在我们每个人的一生中，总会有那么一些时刻，脚下的土地开始摇晃，我们的世界变得不稳定，一切都发生了改变。有时，这种漂泊不定感源于我们失业或结束了一段关系；有时，它来得更为渐进，让我们慢慢意识到，我们所建立的生活并没有像我们想象的那样带来充实感。这些时刻会让人感到迷失、沮丧，但它们也能让我们以全新的方式看待事物。今天，我们继续推出“幸福 2.0”系列节目，探讨一个简单却至关重要的问题：
that we all need in our lives. Purpose is an ancient concept. We, as a species, have been grappling with this concept forever. How cultivating a sense of purpose can help us weather life's biggest storms this week on Hidden Brain. Cornell University Psychologist Anthony Barrow has spent much of his career studying what it means to have a sense of purpose. He has examined how we can cultivate purpose and how having a sense of purpose can transform
我们生活中都极其需要的东西。目标是一个古老的概念。作为一个物种，人类一直在与这个概念纠缠不休。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨如何培养目标感，以帮助我们度过人生中最大的风暴。康奈尔大学心理学家安东尼·巴罗（Anthony Barrow）的大部分职业生涯都在研究拥有目标感意味着什么。他研究了我们如何培养目标感，以及拥有目标感如何能够改变
our lives. Tony Barrow, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Tony, I want to play your short clip from the 1967 movie The Graduate. In this scene, a young Dustin Hoffman plays Benjamin Braddock. He's a fresh out of college, lounging in his parents' pool when his dad confronts him. Ben, what are you doing? Well, I would say that I'm just drifting here in the pool.
我们的人生。托尼·巴罗，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。托尼，我想播放1967年电影《毕业生》中的一个短片。在这场戏中，年轻的达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演本杰明·布拉达克。他刚大学毕业，正懒洋洋地躺在父母家的游泳池里，这时他的父亲质问他。本，你在干嘛？嗯，我想说我只是在泳池里随波逐流。
Why? Well, it's very comfortable just to drift here. Have you thought about graduate school? No. Would you mind telling me then what those four years of college were for, what was the point of all that hard work? You got me. Now listen, Ben.
为什么？嗯，就这样随波逐流感觉很舒服。你想过读研究生吗？没有。那你介意告诉我，那四年的大学是为了什么？所有那些辛苦劳动的意义何在？你把我问住了。听着，本。
Tony, do you ever come by people who sound like Ben, people who are just drifting through life? Frequently, I do. Certainly, at some point in our lives, we all feel that way that what we're ultimately doing is sort of drifting through life, although not everybody's in a pool when doing so. I'm thinking that some of these moments must come especially during transitions in life. When young people are leaving college and going into the workplace or people are in the
托尼，你有没有遇到过像本这样的人，那些在生活中随波逐流的人？我经常遇到。当然，在我们生命中的某个时刻，我们都会有这种感觉，即我们最终所做的一切其实都像是在生活中随波逐流，尽管并非每个人在这样做时都泡在泳池里。我想，其中一些时刻一定特别出现在人生的转折点。当年轻人离开大学进入职场，或者人们处于
middle part of their careers, they're deciding whether they want a second career or whether they want a retire or they're moving into retirement. I'm assuming that these moments might be more likely than others to bring out the sense of self-doubt. Yeah, that's an interesting observation in that maybe feelings of languishing are actually not as random as they may seem, particularly the examples you've given at transition points of having just graduated or having just retired, a lot of the identity contingencies, ways that the ways in which we think ourselves
职业生涯的中期，他们正在决定是想要开始第二职业、退休，还是正在步入退休生活。我猜这些时刻比其他时刻更有可能引发自我怀疑的感觉。是的，这是一个有趣的观察，也许无所适从的感觉实际上并不像看上去那么随机，特别是你所举的例子，在刚毕业或刚退休的转折点上，许多身份偶然性，即我们看待自己的方式，
are interwoven into the everyday life experiences. And so the school relationships I have or the work relationships I have, when those things end or come to an end, it might be that I start to wonder, well, who am I? What am I going to do today? And languishing isn't just a description of sort of wallowing in a pool, a float in a pool. It is an attempt to describe a whole set of effective, emotional, behavioral circumstances of simply not feeling engaged with one's life. There's sort of a disconnection. And so you're sort of in this
都与日常生活体验交织在一起。因此，我拥有的学校关系或工作关系，当这些事情结束或走向终点时，我可能会开始纳闷：好吧，我是谁？我今天要干什么？而无所适从并不仅仅是对在泳池里打滚、漂浮的一种描述。它试图描述一整套情感、情绪和行为上的状况，即简单地感觉不到自己与生活有所投入。这是一种某种程度上的脱节。所以你基本上处于这样一种
space, as I've experienced it, where you can't fully make sense of up or down heads or tails, because you're languishing, you can't keep score of how to move forward and get more of what you want, less of what you don't like. You're sort of in the wind, I think is a good way of describing it. And emotionally, I mean, self-doubt is probably at one end of the spectrum, and at the other end of the spectrum, you know, it can probably go as far as despair of really feeling like you don't know where you're headed and you don't know how to figure out how to get there. I agree. A truly unsettling situation would be to really not know what's next.
空间中——正如我所经历的那样——在那里你无法完全分清上下或头尾，因为你在无所适从，你无法计算该如何前进以获得更多你想要的东西，减少你讨厌的东西。我想，用“随风飘荡”来形容这种状态再合适不过了。在情感上，我是说，自我怀疑可能处于光谱的一端，而在光谱的另一端，你知道，它甚至可能发展到绝望的地步，真的觉得自己不知道前方通往何方，也不知道该如何弄清楚如何到达那里。我同意。真正令人不安的情况就是完全不知道接下来会发生什么。
You can imagine how unsettling that would be for people and confusing, especially when they're in context that are sort of demanding of them answers to the questions, what are you going to do next? And to not have an answer to that can be really off-putting and unsettling. You once ran an experiment where you asked people to report in the morning how purposeful they felt and then report in the evening how purposeful the day had been. What did you find? The people were largely inaccurate.
你可以想象这对人们来说是多么令人不安和困惑，特别是当他们处于那种要求他们回答“接下来你要做什么？”这类问题的环境时。如果对这个问题没有答案，会让人感到非常反感和不安。你曾做过一个实验，让人们在早晨汇报他们感受到了多少目标感，然后在晚上汇报这一天有多大意义。你发现了什么？人们基本上都不太准确。
They tended to overestimate how purposeful they would feel that day. So waking up in the morning feeling like today is going to be a very purposeful day. But when you actually follow up with people at the end of the day, they actually weren't as purposeful as they thought they were going to be. Which is not wholly unsurprising. Life happens, right? And so over the course of the day, you get busy with the tasks of everyday life. You go to work, you have conversations, and oh, by the end of the day, I didn't get to the things I really set out to do. But what it reveals is that it may actually be important to consider the subjective appraisal that we may feel purposeful
他们往往高估了自己那天会感受到的目标感。所以早上醒来时会觉得今天会是非常有目标感的一天。但当你真正在一天结束时进行回访时，他们其实并没有自己想象的那么有目标感。这并不完全出人意料。生活总是充满变数，对吧？所以在一天当中，你会被日常生活的任务占满。你去上班，进行对话，结果到了晚上，我根本没有去做那些我真正打算去做的事情。但这揭示出，考虑主观评估可能真的很重要，我们对目标感的感受
differentially across the day and we may wake up with a lot of energy to go out and conquer the day. But over the course of the day, we may not get quite as near that ultimate potential as we thought. Life can get in the way of feeling as purposeful as we intended to. You mentioned the idea of subjective experience a second ago, and I want to stay with that idea for a moment. Many people confuse a life that has meaning with one that has purpose. You say that meaning involves looking backwards and purpose involves looking forward.
在一天当中是会有所不同的，我们可能会带着满满的活力醒来，准备去征服新的一天。但在这一天结束时，我们可能并没有像想象的那样接近那个终极潜能。生活往往会妨碍我们感受到预期的目标感。刚才你提到了主观体验的概念，我想在这个概念上停留一会儿。许多人把有意义的生活与有目标的生活混淆了。你说意义涉及回顾过去，而目标涉及面向未来。
Can you explain the distinction between those two things? Sure. I certainly think these terms, meaning and purpose, can become sort of conceptually tethered in our minds. Meaning is sort of like making sense of the world as it's happened or is happening, whereas purpose may not be as much about comprehending what's happened as it is about aspiring or attending to accomplish something that's ahead of you. Hmm.
你能解释一下这两者的区别吗？当然。我当然认为意义和目标这两个词在我们的头脑中会在概念上联系在一起。意义有点像去理解已经发生或正在发生的世界，而目标可能不那么关乎理解已经发生的事情，而是关乎渴望或致力于完成前方的事情。嗯。
I feel like we live in a culture that talks a lot about goals, you know, getting into college, graduating from college, getting married, getting promoted. Talk a moment about the difference between having goals and having purpose. Goals might be thought of as intentions that can be accomplished, whereas we tend to think about purpose as an intentionality or life aim, meaning it is always in front of you.
我觉得我们生活在一个经常谈论目标的文化中，你知道，比如考上大学、大学毕业、结婚、升职。请花一点时间谈谈拥有目标（goals）和拥有目标感（purpose）之间的区别。目标可以被看作是可以达成的意图，而我们往往将目标感视为一种意向性或生活方向，这意味着它永远在你的前方。
So, for example, a goal of graduating, I can accomplish that goal. I can set a goal of you. So, for example, a goal of graduating, I can accomplish that goal. I can set a goal of getting a job, but a purpose might be something like being a caring father. I can perhaps evidence it on a given day when I'm at my best, but it's hard to imagine accomplishing that, being fully done with the task of that. And so a purpose might be an organizer of our goals, such that when I accomplish goals, it's my purpose that tells me, what are the goals that I should be pursuing next? You know, I'm thinking about the story of Andrea Agassi, the tennis player, you know, in his autobiography, he writes at one point that even though he was a world champion,
所以，举个例子，毕业是一个目标，我可以达成这个目标。我可以设定一个目标——比如，举个例子，毕业是一个目标，我可以达成这个目标。我可以设定一个找到一份工作目标，但目标感可能类似于“做一个充满关爱的父亲”。我或许可以在某个表现出色的日子里证明这一点，但很难想象这可以被彻底完成，或是把这个任务彻底画上句号。因此，目标感可能是我们各种目标的组织者，每当我达成某些目标时，正是我的目标感在告诉我，我接下来应该追求什么目标。你知道，我正在想网球运动员安德烈·阿加西的故事，你知道，他在自传中曾写道，尽管他曾是世界冠军，
he was desperately unhappy, you know, in a 2017 article in the Guardian, he says, despite being good at it, I had a deep resentment and even hatred of tennis. I felt nothing, every day is groundhog day and what's the point. And to me, that's so poignant that someone who is literally at the top of their game can feel like they are drifting
但他感到绝望般的痛苦，你知道，在《卫报》2017年的一篇文章中，他说，尽管我很擅长打网球，但我对它有着深深的怨恨甚至厌恶。我没有任何感觉，每一天都是土拨鼠日，这有什么意义。对我来说，这太令人心酸了，一个字面意义上处于巅峰状态的人，竟然会觉得自己像泳池里的本杰明·布拉达克一样
just as much as Benjamin Braddock in that swimming pool. someone who is literally at the top of that game can feel like they are drifting just as much as Benjamin Braddock in that swimming pool. Yes, that's a fascinating insight, right? Because it's a very profound goal to strive to be number one and to be successful and have as much talent as it would take to be number one in the world and in anything that you're doing. And perhaps as you're en route to number one, there's always this intentionality. There's always a higher seed that you can move forward to. But what happens when you've accomplished it?
在随波逐流。一个字面意义上处于巅峰状态的人，可以觉得自己就像泳池里的本杰明·布拉达克一样在随波逐流。是的，这是一个迷人的洞察，对吧？因为努力成为第一、取得成功、拥有成为世界第一和做任何事所需的全部天赋，是一个非常深远的目标。也许在你通往第一的路上，始终存在着这种意向性。总有一个更高的种子排名推动你前进。但是，当你真正达成目标之后会发生什么呢？
The game changes. Now it's the story of holding on to that, of maintenance. And so I think that's a wonderful illustration of what can happen when we conflate a goal with a purpose. If a goal can be accomplished, it does raise questions about what becomes of you once you've accomplished it. PURPOSE is not synonymous with what the world sees in front of you.
游戏规则变了。现在，这是一个关于如何守住它、如何维持的故事。所以我想这是一个极好的例证，说明了当我们把“目标（goal）”与“目标感（purpose）”混为一谈时会发生什么。如果一个目标是可以达成的，这确实引发了一个问题：一旦你达成了目标，你会变成什么样？“目标感”并不等同于世界在你面前看到的东西。
It is entirely internally driven. The answer to the question, what is your purpose is not something you can crowdsource. It's not something that you can turn to others and say, hey, tell me from your profile view, which direction does it look like I'm heading in? It's an internal quest and not until you realize that, you begin to ask yourself the question,
它完全是由内在驱动的。回答“你的目标是什么”这个问题，并不是你可以通过群体众包得来的。这不是你可以转向他人说：“嘿，从你的侧面视角来看，我看起来正朝哪个方向前进？”这是一次内心的探索，直到你意识到这一点，你才会开始问自己这个问题：
who are you, what direction are you heading in, what is your purpose, would it really show up and become salient or actionable to you. You know, I feel like poets and philosophers have talked about this idea for a long time. And I love what you just said that in many ways, purpose is not about what it looks like on the outside from your profile picture on Instagram. It really is what's happening on the inside. That's right.
你是谁，你正朝哪个方向前进，你的目标是什么？只有这时，它才会真正显现出来，并对你变得意义重大或具有行动指导意义。你知道，我觉得诗人和哲学家们长期以来一直在讨论这个想法。我非常喜欢你刚才所说的话，在很多方面，目标感并不是关于从你Instagram的头像上看它在外部是什么样子的。它真正关乎的是内部正在发生的事情。没错。
And I think that actually is poignant because there are many examples of people who from the outside look one way, look completely self-directed and clear what they're doing. But when you ask them what direction they're heading in, they may report symptoms of languishing. heading and they may report symptoms of languishing. A lack of purpose can affect us at many different stages of our lives. Young people, like the fictional Benjamin Brattick, might experience it as confusion and
我认为这确实很触动人心，因为有许多这样的例子：外表看起来某种样子的人，看起来完全是自我主导的，对自己在做什么非常清楚。但当你问他们正朝哪个方向前进时，他们可能会报告出无所适从的症状。前进，他们可能会报告出无所适从的症状。缺乏目标感会在我们人生的许多不同阶段影响我们。像虚构人物本杰明·布拉达克这样的年轻人可能会将其体验为困惑和
uncertainty. Working age adults might experience it as on-wee, unending drudgery and tedious routines. Among older Americans, a lack of purpose may be linked to isolation and loneliness. Purpose in other words, is essential to our well-being. It buffers us against the challenges we will all confront at various stages of our lives. It provides a measure of stability in uncertain times. The good news is that purpose is also something we can cultivate. That's when we come back.
不确定性。处于工作年龄的成年人可能会将其体验为倦怠、无休止的苦差事和单调乏味的日常。对于年长的美国人来说，缺乏目标感可能与孤立和孤独息息相关。换句话说，目标感对我们的幸福至关重要。它能缓冲我们在人生各个阶段都将面临的挑战。它在不确定的时期提供了一定程度的稳定。好消息是，目标感也是我们可以培养的东西。广告回来后我们继续。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you had to choose between a million dollars and having a sense of purpose, you might choose the money. At Cornell University, psychologist Anthony Barrow might argue you are making a mistake. Tony, I want to take nothing away from the benefits of having a great job or having money or a roof over your head. Those things are really important, especially if you don't have them. But can you talk a moment about what purpose can give us that money and material comforts cannot?
欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。如果你必须在一百万美元和拥有目标感之间做出选择，你可能会选择金钱。在康奈尔大学，心理学家安东尼·巴罗可能会认为你犯了错误。托尼，我并不是想否定拥有一份好工作、拥有金钱或遮风避雨的房子的好处。这些事情真的很重要，尤其是当你还没有它们的时候。但你能花点时间谈谈，目标感能给我们带来什么金钱和物质安慰无法给予的东西吗？
First and foremost, a sense of purpose could give you a basis on which to decide, given the finite resources we have of money, of time, of energy, how should we best allocate them to allow us to move forward? And so money helps us purchase life's experiences. Which experiences should we purchase? It's fundamentally a different question and having a sense of purpose could clarify that for us. I want to play you a clip from the movie Lost in Translation.
首先也是最重要的一点，目标感可以为你提供一个决策基础：鉴于我们拥有的金钱、时间和精力等有限资源，我们该如何最好地分配它们，才能让我们继续前进？因此，金钱帮助我们购买生活体验。我们应该购买哪些体验？这本质上是一个不同的问题，而拥有目标感可以为我们厘清这一点。我想给你播放一段电影《迷失东京》中的片段。
A younger woman is asking an older man about how to navigate some of life's challenges and I want to play you a little exchange that they have. Does it get easier? No. Yes. It gets easier. No, yeah.
一个年轻女子正在向一个年长的男子询问如何应对生活中的某些挑战，我想播放一小段他们的对话。生活会变得更容易吗？不会。会。会变容易的。不，会。
Look at you. Thanks. The more you know who you are and what you want, the less the other things upset you. The more you know who you are and what you want, the less you're going to let things upset you. Can you talk about the role of purpose as a mood-regulator Tony? There seems to be accumulating evidence that one of the benefits of feeling a sense of purpose is that it can help us remain even keel in moments of stress or challenge and sometimes even uplifting experiences. We've done studies where we ask people to report challenges
看看你。谢谢。你越是了解自己是谁、想要什么，其他事情对你的困扰就越少。你越是了解自己是谁、想要什么，你就越不会让事情困扰你。托尼，你能谈谈目标感作为情绪调节器的作用吗？越来越有证据表明，感受到目标感的好处之一是，它能帮助我们在压力或挑战的时刻，有时甚至是令人振奋的经历中，保持情绪平稳。我们做过一些研究，让人们汇报压力源
or difficult experiences in the unfolding context of their everyday lives. And as you might expect, on days in which people tend to report stressors, they also tend to report increases in distress. They tend to feel worse on days when they're reporting more stressors. However, purposeful individuals or those that tend to score higher than their peers on measures of purpose in life, their stressful days kind of
或者日常生活不断展开的背景下的困难经历。正如你所料，在人们倾向于报告压力源的日子里，他们也倾向于报告痛苦感的增加。在报告更多压力源的日子里，他们往往感觉更糟糕。然而，具有强烈目标感的人，或者那些在生活目标测量中得分高于同龄人的人，他们充满压力的日子
look like non-stressful days for the rest of us. In other words, it's almost as if it's helping them navigate or smooth the course for them. Now, I should say, it's almost as if it's helping them navigate or smooth the course for them. Now I should say, it is not the case that purposeful people experience any less stress or challenge in their lives. In fact, in our studies, sometimes purposeful people report more day-to-day stressors than their peers who report lower levels of purpose in life. But on days in which people tend to report stressors, having a sense of purpose seems to buffer or mitigate the ill-intended consequences of stressors. So it's almost as if having purpose allows you to keep your eyes on the horizon, if you will,
对我们其他人来说，看起来就像是没有压力的日子一样。换句话说，这几乎就像是在帮助他们驾驭或为他们平息道路。现在，我应该说，这几乎就像是在帮助他们驾驭或为他们平息道路。现在我应该说，并不是说有目标感的人在生活中经历的压力或挑战就会减少。事实上，在我们的研究中，有目标感的人有时会比那些生活目标得分较低的同龄人报告更多日常压力源。但在人们倾向于报告压力源的日子里，拥有目标感似乎可以缓冲或减轻压力源带来的不良后果。因此，这就好比拥有目标感能让你放眼未来（如果你愿意这么说的话），
so that the day-to-day challenges that are both, you know, the good and bad tend to knock you off course a little less, because in some ways your eyes are focused on the future. That's correct. And what's remarkable about this growing set of studies is it seems to be evident both in the context of stressors and in the context of positive events or uplifts. So on days when good things happen, as you'd expect, people tend to report increases in things like positive affect, life satisfaction or self-esteem. But individuals who score high and measures of purpose in life, on those days when
从而让那些好坏兼有的日常挑战不那么容易让你偏离方向，因为在某种程度上，你的目光聚焦在未来。没错。这组不断增加的研究引人注目的一点是，在压力源的背景下以及在积极事件或提升心情的事件背景下，它似乎都十分明显。因此，当好事发生时，正如你所料，人们往往会报告积极情感、生活满意度或自尊等方面的增加。但在生活目标测量中得分很高的人身上，在那些好事发生的日子里，
good things happen, they tend to look emotionally even keel. It's almost as if that good thing didn't happen. And I'll just say, although that may be jarring at first, it's like purpose almost blocks you from reaping the benefits of a good thing. Over time, you would not want your emotional tone to be bouncing around based upon the experiences that are happening to you.
他们的情绪往往显得波澜不惊。就好像那件好事根本没有发生过一样。我只想说，尽管这起初可能会让人觉得有些突兀，就好像目标感几乎阻碍了你收获好事带来的好处一样。随着时间的推移，你肯定不希望自己的情绪基调根据发生在你身上的经历而上下起伏。
Over the course of one's lifespan, it might be beneficial to remain even keel or as close as possible to life's experiences and feel good irrespective of what's happening around you. You once asked volunteers in an experiment to climb a steep hill, and at the bottom of the hill, some were asked to write about a movie,
在人的一生中，保持情绪平稳，或者尽可能贴近生活的种种体验，并且无论周围发生什么都感觉良好，这可能会更有益处。你曾在一次实验中要求志愿者爬一座陡峭的山坡，在山坡底部，一些人被要求写一部电影，
and others were asked to write about something that gave them a sense of purpose. Can you tell us what you found once the volunteer has got to the top of the hill? In this particular experiment, after writing about either the movie that they had seen or their sense of purpose, individuals traversed a steep incline. And as they arrived at the top, we asked them to report how steep was this hill and how much effort did it take them to get to the top. Now, for those individuals who had written about the most recent movie they had seen, there was a pretty clear positive correlation or a strong relationship between how steep they thought the hill was and how much effort they thought
而另一些人被要求写一些能给他们带来目标感的事情。你能告诉我们，当志愿者到达山顶后，你发现了什么吗？在这个特定的实验中，在写完他们看过的电影或写完他们的目标感之后，个人需要穿过一个陡峭的斜坡。当他们到达山顶时，我们要求他们汇报这座山有多陡，以及他们花了多少力气才到达山顶。现在，对于那些写了他们看过的最新电影的人来说，他们认为山有多陡与他们认为爬到山顶花了多少力气之间，存在着相当明显的正相关关系或强烈的联系。
it took to get to the top. Whereas individuals who had written about purpose, briefly before traversing this incline, when they got to the top, they showed less of a relationship between the estimated incline of the hill and how much effort they said it took to get to the top. One thing I should say, because I think it's relevant to the conversation, is we also had another condition in this study in which we asked people to write about their goals, that they intended to accomplish once they got to the top of the hill, to study with a friend, to meet somebody for lunch, to go home, whatever they might say that they were
而那些在穿过这个斜坡之前简短写了关于目标感的人，当他们到达山顶时，他们对山体倾斜度的估计与他们所说到达山顶所需努力之间的关系则没有那么强烈。我应该说的一件事，因为我认为它与这次对话相关，我们在本研究中还有另一个条件，我们要求人们写下他们的目标，即他们打算在到达山顶后完成的目标，比如和朋友一起学习、和某人见面吃午饭、回家，无论他们可能说他们到达山顶后要做什么。
going to do once they got to the top of the hill. And those individuals who wrote about a goal, they actually did not show the same relationship between estimated incline and reported effort as the purpose-writing condition. And I think the insight to be drawn here is, goals can become obstacles to the thing you most want to do. If you get me to think about my goal, well then this hill is the effort. This is the obstacle between me and where I'm going to be
而那些写下目标的人，其实并没有表现出像写目标感条件下的那种“估计倾斜度与报告努力程度”之间的关系。我认为这里可以得出的见解是：目标会成为你最想做的事情的绊脚石。如果你让我去想我的目标，那么这座山就是一种努力。这就是我和我几分钟后到达山顶时要去的地方之间的障碍，而目标感似乎在某种程度上将这些事情解耦了，因为我没有在想我到达山顶后马上要做什么。我在想我人生的总体方向。我还了解到，有研究表明，拥有目标感的人
in a few minutes when I get to the top, whereas a sense of purpose seem to decouple those things in a way, because I'm not thinking about what I'm going to do immediately at the top. I'm thinking about my general direction in life. I also understand there's been research that suggests that people who have a sense of
似乎对其他人更有吸引力。这可能吗?确实有一些暗示性的证据表明，报告在生活中具有更强目标感的人具有一种人际吸引力。这是泰勒·斯蒂尔曼（Tyler Stillman）及其同事的研究。他们表明，我们对人们吸引力的判断似乎与个人感受到目标感的强烈程度之间存在这种潜在的关系。我不认为这真的只关乎身体吸引力，
purpose appear more attractive to others. Is that possibly true? There does seem to be some suggestive evidence that individuals who report a stronger sense of purpose in life have a kind of interpersonal appeal. This is the work of Tyler Stillman and his colleagues. They have shown that our sort of judgments of attractiveness of people seem to have this sort of latent relationship with how strongly of a sense of purpose an individual might feel. And it's not really, I don't think, a story of just physical attractiveness,
而是一个关于讨人喜欢、想和某人待在一起或想和他们交朋友的故事。他们的数据表明，在目标感测量中得分高的人往往能享受到周围世界带来的这种好处。这就好像我们可以看到这个人正朝着某个方向前进。他们身上有种特质，他们是有方向性的。
but a story of just likeability and wanting to be a round person or wanting to be a round person or wanting to be friends with them. Their data suggests that people who score highly on measures of purpose tend to enjoy this benefit of the world around them. It's almost as if we can see that this person is heading somewhere. There's something about them and they have a directionality to them.
你知道，当我读泰勒·斯蒂尔曼的研究时，我想起了几年前读过的一首诗，作者是W.H.奥顿（W. H. Auden），他在诗中探讨了完全相同的观点。他说，你不需要看一个人在做什么，就知道这是否是他的天职。你只需观察他的眼睛：一个正在搅拌酱汁的厨师，一个正在做第一次切口的 chirurg（外科医生），一个正在填写提单的职员，
You know, as I was reading Tyler Stilman's study, I remember the poem that I had read some years ago, this is by WHO Auden, where he talks about the very same idea. He says, you need not see what someone is doing to know if it is his vocation. You have only to watch his eyes, a cook mixing a sauce, a surgeon making a primary incision, a clerk completing a bill of lading,
他们都有着同样专注的表情，在职能中忘却了自我。我看着这个对象，是多么的美丽啊。我想知道，托尼，当你听到这首诗时，这是否印证了你刚才所说的话：在某种程度上，有某种东西——它不是那种身体吸引力意义上的吸引力，而是某种吸引我们去接近那些似乎真正投入到他们正在做的事情中的人的特质。首先，我认为这首诗很美，有趣的是，有暗示性证据表明，在感受到目标感的测量中得分高的人往往拥有更广、更深的人际网络。所以这就好像他们正在从事的某项事业需要
where the same wrapped expression, forgetting themselves in a function. How beautiful it is that I on the object look. I'm wondering Tony, when you listen to that poem, is this speaking to what you said a second ago that in some ways there's something, it's not sort of attractive in sort of a physical attractiveness sense, but it's something that draws us to people who seem to be truly engaged in what they're doing. First, I think the poem is beautiful, and interestingly, there is suggestive evidence that people who score highly on measures of felt purpose tend to have broader and deeper social networks. So it's as if there may be something they're up to that requires
他们与更广阔的社区圈子建立联系。但同样很有可能的是，当你追求对你来说有意义的事情时，那里面有一种吸引力。人们会找到你，因为你正朝着一个方向前进，这也许又回到了那个无所适从的观点：如果一个人没有方向，如果一个人没有感受到目标感并不开始追求某个特定的目标，你周围的世界可能就更难知道该如何与你建立联系。但似乎如果你是有方向的、正在朝着一个方向前进，那么你知道的，或许周围会产生一种具有吸引力且能被他人感知到的能量。
them to be in connection with broader circles of community. But it could also just as easily be the case that when you're pursuing something that is meaningful to you, there's an attractiveness to that. That people find you because you're headed in a direction and maybe goes back to this languishing point with a person is not directed, if a person does not feel a sense of purpose and start to pursue a particular aim, it may be more difficult for the world around you to know just how to connect to you But it seems like if you're if you're directed you're heading in a direction. There you know, perhaps there's an energy around that that is attractive and imperceptible by others.
托尼和他的同事们通过提出几个非常简单的问题来衡量人们是否有目标感。你可以问自己这些问题。事实上，你现在就可以问自己这些问题。你觉得生活有明确的方向吗？你觉得你的日常活动很有吸引力吗？很重要吗？这就引出了一个至关重要的观点。
Tony and his colleagues measure whether people have a sense of purpose by asking some remarkably simple questions. You can ask yourself these questions. In fact, you can ask yourself these questions right now. Do you feel your life has a clear direction? Do you feel your daily activities are engaging? Important? This leads us to a crucial idea.
目标感不是客观真理，而是主观体验。我和我的同事们倾向于将目标感视为一种感觉——不是客观真理，而是主观体验。我和我的同事们倾向于将目标感视为一种感觉，一种能够感知到生活有方向感的感觉。因此，这仅仅是感觉你的生活有目标，而这似乎是健康和幸福感的强有力预测指标。那么让我们来谈谈健康和幸福感这个概念。
A sense of purpose is not an objective truth, but a subjective experience. My colleagues and I tend to think about purpose as a sense, is not an objective truth, but a subjective experience. My colleagues and I tend to think about purpose as a sense, a perceptible sense that life has a sense of direction. So it's simply feeling like your life has purpose, which seems to be a strong predictor of health and well-being. So let's talk about the idea of health and well-being for a moment.
研究对拥有目标感与健康结果之间的联系是怎么说的？我能分享的最引人注目的发现之一就是，拥有生活目标感可以预测长寿。但除了长寿之外，还有一系列的研究表明，目标感与一系列身体和生理健康结果息息相关。例如，有目标感的人报告的心脏病发作或中风的发病率较低。有目标感的人从某些类型的手术中恢复得更快。
What is the research say about the connections between having a sense of purpose and health outcomes? One of the most compelling findings I could think to share is that having a sense of purpose of life predicts longevity. But beyond longevity, there is a whole constellation of studies to suggest. Purpose is associated with a whole host of physical and physiological health outcomes. For example, purposeful individuals report lower incidence of heart attack or stroke. Purposeful individuals recover faster from certain kinds of surgery.
有目标感的人报告感到的心理生理症状更少，比如在日常生活背景下的头痛和胃痛。因此，目标感的健康状况似乎格外积极。我了解到，目标感还带来认知方面的好处。当然。
Purposeful people report feeling less psychosomatic symptoms, so headaches and stomach aches in the context of their everyday lives. So the health profile of purpose seems to be especially positive. I understand there are also cognitive benefits that come with a sense of purpose. Sure.
所以还有暗示性证据表明，有目标感的人……当然。因此，也有暗示性证据表明，有目标感的人在衰老过程中表现出较慢的认知能力下降速度，并且患阿尔茨海默病的风险也较低。所以确实有暗示性证据表明，目标感再次与一系列认知益处相关联。
So there's also suggestive evidence that individuals with a sense of purpose? Sure. So there's also suggestive evidence that individuals with a sense of purpose show slower rates of cognitive decline over the course of aging and lower risk of developing Alzheimer's disease as well. So there's indeed suggestive evidence that purpose is associated with, again, a host of cognitive benefits.
我们在本期节目开始时谈到了一个思想实验，我让你在拥有一百万美元和拥有目标感之间做出选择。然而在现实中，你和其他人发现，拥有目标感往往并不与财务成功相冲突。在某些方面，这两者可能是相关的。你能谈谈那项研究吗？当然。
We spoke at the beginning of the segment about a thought experiment where I was giving you the choice between having a million dollars and having a sense of purpose. In reality though, you and others have found that having a sense of purpose is not often at odds with financial success. And in some ways the two things might be correlated. Can you talk about that work? Sure.
在我们的实验室里，我们注意到拥有生活目标感与更高的自我报告收入和更高的净资产有关。我想结合另一项研究来谈谈这一点，因为这里有一个重要的联系，即拥有目标感也与较低水平的冲动性有关。因此，在一项研究中，如果给人们一个机会，让他们现在就获得一笔小额金钱奖励，他们往往会选择在未来获得一笔更大的奖励。而“在生活中拥有目标感与较低水平的冲动性有关”这一概念，我认为阐明了具有目标感的人可能正在玩的一场“长线游戏”。他们考虑的不是此时此地，而是储蓄，是为了以后创造更多。我想知道你能否谈谈目标感，
In the context of our lab, we've noted having a sense of purpose in life is associated with greater self-reported income and greater net worth. And I want to speak to this in relationship to another study because I think there's an important relationship here, is having a sense of purpose is also associated with lower levels of impulsivity. So in a study where individuals were given a chance to take right now a small monetary reward, they tended to opt for a larger downstream reward. And the notion that having a sense of purpose in life is implicated in lower levels of impulsivity, I think illuminates the long game that purposeful individuals might be playing. They're thinking about not the here and now, but about saving, about generating more for later. I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about purpose
而不是在个人层面上。这可能很难做到，因为在社会层面上很难进行实验。但在我看来，在不同社会的生命中，总会有那么一些时刻，社会觉得他们有目标，而有时社会觉得他们随波逐流。你能谈谈这种将目标感作为变革驱动力的想法吗，尤其是在宏观层面上，即社会层面？你知道，我必须坦白，我们倾向于将目标感衡量为一种个人资产，一种个人可以培养的个人资源。但这在集体意义上是什么样子的呢？
not at an individual level. And this might be difficult to do because it's harder to run experiments at a societal level. But it seems to me that there are times in the lives of different societies when societies feel like they have purpose and when societies feel like they are adrift. Can you talk about this idea of purpose as a driver of change, especially at the large level, to societal level? You know, I have to confess, we tend to measure purpose as this individual asset, this individual resource that a person could cultivate. But what does that
我可以说，我甚至在政治言论中也注意到，当候选人呼吁我们共同的目标感时，这提醒我们，即使作为个人，我们也属于比我们自身更宏大的事物。我必须去山顶。我眺望过远方，看到了应许之地。我可能无法与你们一同到达那里，但我希望你们知道，我们这个民族终将抵达应许之地。马丁·路德·金博士在阐述他的梦想时，邀请我们想象一个尚未存在的世界。我认为这又是一个深刻的见解，揭示了“我们能够完成的目标”与“在很久很久之后我们仍能致力于朝着它迈进的目标感”之间的区别。那种雄心勃勃的基调是如此生动，甚至在他提醒我们他
look like in a collective sense? I can say, I notice even in political rhetoric when candidates call on our collective sense of purpose. It is a reminder that even as an individual we belong to something larger than ourselves. I have me to go out to the mountain. I've looked over and I've seen the promised land. I may not get that with you, but I want you to know the night that we as a people will get to the promised land. In his articulation of a dream, Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. invited us to imagine a world that was not yet present. And I think that's a profound, yet again, a profound insight into a distinction between a goal that we can accomplish and a purpose that long after us, we can still be intending to move towards. The aspirational tone is so vivid, even in his reminder that he
可能不会和我们一起到达那里时，但这一切仍然值得付出努力。这一切仍然值得去追求，并提醒我们有力量将这一点传承下去。我想给你播放一段已故的维克多·弗兰克尔（Viktor Frankl）的访谈片段，他是大屠杀幸存者，也是畅销书《活出意义来》（Man's Search for Meaning）的作者。这是他在一次采访中的发言。我们在奥斯威辛集中营和其他集中营里能够学到的最少的东西，归根结底是战争。那些以未来要由他们去实现的某种意义为导向的人，是最有可能活下来的人。后来，美国海军和陆军精神病学家在日本战俘营中也证实了这一点。
may not arrive there with us, but it was still worth the effort. It was still worth the pursuit and reminding us that we are empowered to carry this forward. I want to play you a clip from the late Viktor Frankl, Holocaust survivor and author of the best-selling book, Man's Search for Meaning. Here he is in an interview. The less than one could learn in Auschwitz and in other concentration camps in the final analysis wars. Those who were oriented toward a meaning to be fulfilled by them in the future were most likely to survive. And this has been confirmed afterwards by American Navy and Army Psychiatrists in Japanese Prison of War camps.
这种朝向未来的导向、朝向一项任务的导向——一项等待他们在未来去完成的个人任务，或者是等待他们再次相聚的心爱之人——正是这些人在集中营里得以坚守的关键所在。因此，你看，这种超越自我的导向，问题不仅在于生存，而且必须有一个生存的“理由（why）”。托尼，请谈谈这一点，因为这是一个如此重要且强大的想法，正如维克多·弗兰克尔所说，即使在集中营的人间地狱里，问题也不仅仅是生存，为了生存，还必须有一个“为什么”。这是对“你是否有生存理由”这个问题最雄辩的阐述。
The orientation taught a future, taught a task, a personal task, waiting for them to be fulfilled in their future, or another person whom they were loving, to be met again. This was what was decisively upheld in these people. So, the orientation beyond oneself, you see, the question was not just survivors, but there had to be a why of survivor. Tony, talk about this a moment because there's such an important and powerful idea that even in the horrors of the concentration camp, the question was not just survival, as Victor Frankel says, but there had to be a why in order to have survival. It is the most eloquent putting of the question, do you have a reason for living?
我想更好的说法是：可能会发生肉体上的死亡，维克多·弗兰克尔对此有着敏锐的察觉。但在那之前，可能会发生心理上的死亡，即一个人在前方看不到任何其他东西。我想他所表达的是一种深刻的必要性：感觉到前方有什么东西。有些事情是你尚未完成的，你可以朝着它前进，以此作为生存的方式，作为心理上的生存和坚持的方式。
I guess the better way of saying this is, there can be a physical death, and Victor Franco was very keenly aware of that. But before that, there can be a psychological death where a person sees nothing else out ahead of themselves. And I think what he's speaking to is the profound necessity of feeling like there is something out in front of you. There is something that you have yet to accomplish that you can move towards as a way of surviving, of psychologically surviving and persisting.
并坚持下去。目标是一个古老的概念。作为一个物种，人类一直在与这个概念纠缠不休。但我认为维克多·弗兰克尔的贡献在于，我们可以认真对待将目标感视为一种深刻而强大的心理资源的探索，这种资源值得我们花时间去培养，这样我们就能看到自己在时间中坚持不懈，并最终为眼前的世界做出贡献。广告回来后，我们要说的是：说目标感非常重要是一回事。但如果你没有它，你该如何找到它？目标感是需要去发现的东西，还是可以被发展、打磨和培养的？欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
and persisting. Purpose is an ancient concept. We, as a species, have been grappling with this concept forever. But I think Victor Franco's contribution is that we can take seriously the psychological enterprise of purpose as a deep and profound resource that is worth taking our time to cultivate the sense so that we see ourselves persisting in time and ultimately contributing to the world that is before us. When we come back, it's one thing to say that purpose is really important. But if you don't have it, how do you find it? Is purpose something to be discovered or can it be developed, honed and cultivated? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。拥有目标感就像拥有秘密的超能力。心理学家安东尼·巴罗认为，它可以改善你的健康、认知能力和寿命。它甚至能让你显得更有吸引力。我们讨论过网球运动员安德烈·阿加西，以及尽管他非常成功，他却如何开始痛恨网球。但这并不是阿加西故事的全部。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Having a sense of purpose is like a secret superpower. Psychologist Anthony Barrow argues it can improve your health, your cognitive abilities, your longevity. It can even make you appear more attractive. We've talked about the tennis player, Andrea Agassi, and how, even though he was very successful, he came to hate tennis. But that's not the end of Agassi's story.
当他意识到自己的生活感到空虚时，安德烈·阿加西决定以不同的方式对待网球。他意识到人们来看球、来打球是因为他给别人带来了快乐。他开始把自己当作榜样。以下是他描述自己对自己的选择承担责任的旅程。承担责任意味着对存在以及重新开始的机会心存感激。从我自己挖的那个洞里爬出来，就在那时，我开始选择相信我们每个人对生活都有一个计划，一个要实现的宏伟目标，一份要创造的成就可以，一个存在的理由。
When he realized his life felt empty, Andrea Agassi decided to approach tennis differently. He realized people were coming to watch and play that he was giving others joy. He started to see himself as a role model. Here he is describing that journey of taking ownership over his choices. Ownership meant feeling grateful for being and having the chance to start over. Climbing out of that hole that I dug for myself, that's when I started choosing to believe that each of us have a plan for our life, a purpose to fulfill, body of work to create, a reason to be.
托尼，你似乎有着非凡的好运，在人生的很大一部分时间里都拥有方向感。我想谈谈你成长过程中经历的一些事情，这些事情可能对你的这段旅程有所帮助。你小时候被收养，你是黑人，你的父母是白人。你很容易觉得自己像一条离开水的鱼。但你在很早的时候就接触到了一个名为“4-H（四H俱乐部）”的项目。请告诉我你是在哪里长大的，对于许多不在美国的《隐藏的大脑》听众来说，
Tony, you seem to have had the remarkable good fortune of having a sense of direction through much of your life. I want to talk about some things you experienced growing up that may have helped you on this journey. You were adopted as a child, your black, your parents are white. You could very easily have come to see yourself as a fish out of water. But early on, you encountered a program called 4H. Tell me where you grew up and for the many hidden brain listeners who are not in the United States.
4-H项目是什么？它是如何触动你的生活的？4-H是一个已经存在了115年以上的全国性青年发展项目。当我还是个孩子的时候，我参加了一个4-H项目。我住在艾奥瓦州，艾奥瓦州东北部的布雷默县。所以向我曾加入的布雷默县4-H项目致敬！我的4-H项目高度集中于农业发展。它给参与这个项目的年轻人提供了学习农业技能、如何种植农作物、如何照顾动物等类似事情的机会。我从未想过参加4-H真的是在参与一个项目。这只是当时觉得很酷的一件值得去做的事。
What is the 4H program and how did it touch your life? 4-H is a national youth development program that has been in existence for over 115 years. And when I was a child, I participated in a 4-H program. I was living in Iowa, Northeast Iowa in Bremer County. So shout out to the Bremer County 4-H program that I was a part of. My 4-H program was heavily centered on agricultural development. And it gave the young people that were involved in this program a chance to learn agricultural skills, how to grow crops, how to take care of animals, that kind of thing. I never thought about being in 4H as participating in really a program. It was just kind of the cool thing to do.
什么是4-H项目？它又是如何触动你的生活的？4-H是一个已经存在了115年以上的全国青少年发展项目。当我还是个孩子的时候，我参加过4-H项目。当时我住在衣阿华州，也就是东北部衣阿华州的布雷默县。向我曾参与过的布雷默县4-H项目致敬！我的4-H项目主要围绕农业发展展开。它为参与这个项目的年轻人提供了学习农业技能、如何种植农作物、如何照顾动物等类似事情的机会。我从未想过参加4-H是在参加一个真正的项目。这只是当时一件很酷的事情。
I didn't remember joining anything or signing up. It was just all of my friends and the parents of my friends were involved with 4H. It was a way in which we were socialized into the work that we did from day to day. Help me understand how a program that taught you how to farm, how to raise animals, how does that help you become a psychologist at Cornell University? I don't see the path. That's a wonderful question. Within the context of 4H, we had just a tremendous number of opportunities to practice different things. And one of the things we were invited to practice was public speaking. We had to present lessons we were learning
我并不记得自己加入过什么或注册过什么。只是我的所有朋友以及朋友的父母都参与了4H俱乐部。这是我们日常工作被社会化的一种方式。请帮我理解，一个教你如何耕作、如何养动物的项目，怎么能帮你成为康德大学的心理学家呢？我看不出其中的联系。这是一个很好的问题。在4H俱乐部的环境中，我们有大量练习各种事情的机会。而我们被邀请练习的事情之一就是公众演讲。我们必须展示我们正在学习的课程
to other four-age members in different venues. Sometimes it was our closest friends and families, other times it was strangers at county fairs or state fairs. But over the years, I had a chance to present on how to notch pigs years and the different ways of doing that. I had a chance to present on how to tie different kinds of knots. In one particular time, I had a chance to present on how to tie different kinds of knots.
与其他4H俱乐部成员在不同的场合进行交流。有时是我们最亲密的朋友和家人，有时是县集市或州集市上的陌生人。但在过去的几年里，我有机会介绍如何给猪打耳标以及这样做的不同方法。我有机会介绍如何打各种结。在特定的一次机会中，我有机会介绍如何打各种结。
In one particular time, I had a chance to present on how to grow certain crops in different soil types. And over the years of public speaking and presenting, I think I actually got good at it. I remember in one particular moment of presenting on how to grow certain crops and the judges paying attention to my presentation, taking notes of my style and the delivery and the different things I was saying about the soil. But I also remember the audience. There were people who were not actually judging me, but there to learn about different crop
在某一次特定的机会中，我有机会介绍如何在不同土壤类型中种植某些农作物。通过多年的公众演讲和展示，我认为我真的在这方面变得很擅长。我记得在某一次介绍如何种植某些农作物时，评委们正在认真听我的演讲，并记录我的风格、表达方式以及我关于土壤所说的各种事情。但我也记得观众。有些人其实不是来评判我的，而是来了解不同的农作物
types and soil types. And that, to be, you know, eight or nine years old, presenting to an audience of adults, teaching adults about the thing that I knew about was a profound experience. And I had a little jar where I was showing different layers of the soil. And I remember going away and coming back and seeing the judges had placed a red ribbon
类型和土壤类型的。而且，作为一个八九岁的孩子，向成年观众做演讲，向成年人传授我所知道的事物，这是一次深刻的体验。我有一个小罐子，用来展示土壤的不同层次。我记得我离开了一会儿又回来，看到评委们在我的演讲上放了一条红丝带
around my presentation, which essentially translated to second place. And I've always been pretty salty about that day, that I got a second place on a presentation. But it stuck with me, that I realized I had something to say, and the way I went about saying it mattered, because people might understand the world they're living in differently as a function of what I'm saying.
这基本上意味着第二名。对于那天我获得演讲第二名这件事，我一直感到有些耿耿于怀。但这深深印在了我的脑海里，我意识到自己有话要说，我表达的方式也很重要，因为人们可能会根据我所说的话，以不同的方式理解他们所生活的世界。
I could get better. There was room for improvement, but that was a profound experience for me as a young person. So one of the things that jumped out of me at what you just said was that you discovered that you had something to say. And part of who was actually discovering a little bit of who you were, and what kind of a person you were. Can you talk about this connection between programs that in some ways help people discover who they are, discover a sense of identity, and the really vital connection between a sense of identity and having a sense of purpose?
我可以做得更好。还有改进的空间，但对于我这个年轻人来说，这是一次深刻的体验。所以，你刚才所说的话中，有一个吸引我的地方是，你发现自己有话要说。而这其中的一部分，其实也是在探索你是谁，以及你是一个什么样的人。你能谈谈这之间的联系吗？一方面是那些在某种程度上帮助人们发现自我、发现认同感的项目，另一方面是认同感与目标感之间至关重要的联系。
Right. It turns out, after all, that 4H is, in fact, a youth development program, a well-intended program of scaffolded experiences. And what's really neat about this is that there's a growing course of studies to suggest certain features of youth programs have the ability to invite young people to cultivate a sense of who they are and where they're going. And I would nominate for each as one that does this quite well. Specifically, opportunities that told me,
对的。毕竟事实证明，4H俱乐部实际上是一个青年发展项目，是一个精心设计的、循序渐进的体验项目。这个项目真正妙的地方在于，越来越多的研究表明，青年项目的某些特征能够引导年轻人去培养“我是谁”以及“我要去哪里”的意识。而我认为4H俱乐部就是这样一个表现得相当出色的项目。具体来说，那些告诉我以下信息的机遇：
I can learn something about the world that the world doesn't yet know, right? Or some, I can learn something about the world that some people in the world don't yet know. And I can share that information with them. And that was a really important experience for me as a young person. And I think from there, questions of who we are, or questions of identity, are really important, especially informative years, of figuring out, who am I? What role can I play?
我可以了解一些世界上尚未被世界所知晓的事情，对吧？或者说，我可以了解一些世界上某些人尚且不知道的事情。然后我可以与他们分享这些信息。对于我这个年轻人来说，这是一次非常重要的体验。我认为从那时起，我是谁的问题，或者说认同感的问题，就变得非常重要，尤其是在塑造性格的几年里，去琢磨：我是谁？我能扮演什么角色？
And once we've grappled with questions of who we are, we might begin to wonder, where, who am I gonna be? What direction am I heading in? And I think there we see that the link between identity and purpose is really important, because if we were to ask somebody, well, what is your purpose? Well, the you or the you're in that sentence
一旦我们解决了“我是谁”的问题，我们可能就会开始思考：我要去哪里？我要成为什么样的人？我正朝着什么方向前进？我认为在这里我们可以看到，认同感和目标感之间的联系非常重要，因为如果我们去问一个人：“你的目标是什么？”那么这句话里的“你”或“你的”
requires that they know who they are. And so I think we think we might start to think of identity as sort of a foundational layer of self-understanding that when you are equipped with a sense of identity, you might stand a chance at figuring out and cultivating your sense of purpose. So you sometimes, chief, at the suggestion that people should find their purpose or discover their purpose, you would prefer that people think about purpose as something to be cultivated. I can't help but, of course, see the farming metaphor there of sort of cultivation at work. But can you talk about that idea that purpose might not be something that's lying in the ground for us to pick up, but something that really might require our engagement with the soil, if you will, to cultivate it. Yeah, that's that's that's
这样。因此，我猜你可能会离开4H俱乐部，但4H俱乐部永远不会真正离开你，因为我确实是用这种术语来思考的，你知道的，有一种广泛的理解甚至是常规说法，即你可以找到目标。事实上，你应该走向世界去寻找目标。实际上，你应该走向世界去寻找目标。我只是觉得，支撑“目标可以被找到”这一观点的证据并不充分。我确实理解为什么我们可能会得出这样的认识：我可以走到世界上并找到这个东西。如果我有一把合适的手电筒，如果你告诉我往哪里看，
right. So I suspect you can leave 4-H but 4-H will never really leave you because I do think of in those terms is, you know, there's a kind of broad understanding and even prescription that you can find purpose. And in fact, you should go out into that you can find purpose. And in fact, you should go out into the world and find purpose. I just don't see the evidence behind the idea that purpose can be found. I do understand why we might arrive at an understanding that I can go out into the world and find this thing. If I just had the right flashlight, if you tell me where to look,
但我认为这其实并不是它的运作方式。目标的获得似乎源于以下三条路径中的至少一条。目标可能诞生于对某个主题或机遇进行渐进的、持续的尝试。有点像爱好。每当我有空闲时间时，我发现自己会一遍又一遍地追求某样东西，随着时间的推移，我开始思考：“嘿，这是我正在走的一条路吗？这是我的目标吗？”每当我有时间时，我总是回到同一件事情上。我通过渐进式的探索和培养来找到目标。或者我们可能通过反应式的路径来达成目标，生活中发生了一些事情。
but I don't think that's actually how it works. Purpose acquisition seems to arrive off of at least one of three pathways. Purpose might be born out of a gradual, sustained attempt to engage with some topic or opportunity. Kind of like a hobby. Whenever I have downtime, I find myself pursuing something over and over, and over time, I start to think, hey, is this a pathway that I'm on? Is this my purpose? Whenever I have time, I keep going back to the same thing. I sort of arrive at purpose by gradual exploration and cultivation. Or we might arrive at through reactive pathways, something happened in life.
我家的某个人生病了，这倒不一定非得是负面的情况，但在这样的情况下，目标可能会呼唤我投入其中。你可能会想，发生了这件事，现在我确切地知道了人生的方向。这两种路径（主动路径和反应路径）有趣的地方在于，这些个体
Someone in my family felt ill, and it need not be negative, but in instances like that, purpose may sort of call me into it. You might think, this thing happened, and now I know exactly the direction of my life. What's interesting about those two pathways, proactive and reactive, is those individuals
所以他们看着环境中的某个人，培养他们的目标感。现在，你可能不一定会感受到和他们完全相同的感受，但这可能表明你近距离地看到了它是什么样子的。你看到了清晨醒来并真正为之奋斗是什么样子的。总而言之，托尼和其他研究人员已经确定了通往目标的三个不同途径。第一种途径中，当我们追求激情或爱好时，目标会逐渐向我们走来。它会变得越来越大，并积蓄动量，就像滚下山的雪球一样。
may feel equally purposeful, but one has clarity about where it came from, the reactive pathway. They know exactly where that was from, whereas the proactive pathway might fail to recognize when that really began. It was like a snowball. I kept pushing over time. A third pathway might be the social learning pathway. There are some individuals who feel a profound sense of purpose in life, but they nominate learning about that purpose from other people.
另一条途径则是对重大生活事件的回应。家庭成员生病需要我们的帮助。我们失业了，不得不重塑自我。第三种途径是观察一个有目标的人，并从他们的榜样中汲取灵感。在托尼自己的生活中，他通过将童年经历与成年后的工作结合起来，培养了目标感。我有这样一个绝佳的机会担任教授。我得以向人们传授心理学和人类发展方面的知识。每年春天，我都教授一个大型的青少年班。我走进去，看到300张面孔看着我。
So they watched somebody in their environment, cultivate their sense of purpose. Now, it may not be the case that you feel the same sense that they feel, but it might suggest that you've seen what it looks like up close. You saw what it looks like to wake up in the morning and to really go after it. So to recap, Tony and other researchers have identified three different pathways to purpose. In the first, purpose comes to us gradually as we pursue a passion or a hobby. It can become bigger and gain momentum, like a snowball rolling down a hill.
这超级令人畏惧。在过去的十年里，在我讲课前的每一天，在我走进教室之前，我都会在走廊里停留一会儿。我真的会想起我向人们展示信息的所有经历，这些经历可以追溯到我在爱荷华州布雷默县的4H俱乐部时光。当时我演讲的主题是土壤，顺便说一句，我拿了红丝带，因为我把它叫作泥土而不是土壤。这就是吸取的教训。
Another pathway comes in response to a major life event. A family member gets sick and needs our help. We lose a job and have to reinvent ourselves. The third pathway is to observe someone else who has purpose and to draw inspiration from their example. In his own life, Tony has cultivated purpose by linking his childhood experiences with what he does as an adult. I have this wonderful opportunity to serve as a professor. I get to teach people about psychology and human development. And every spring I teach a large adolescence class. I walk in and there's 300 faces looking at me.
最终成为一名教授并不是我的目标。但我确实有一种方向感，而且我确实有一种感觉，随着时间的推移，我正在学习的课程、正在经历和收集的体验，最终会对我有益。到目前为止，事实的确如此。你知道，刚才你关于通往目标的这三条途径说的一番话中，其中一点是：你追求一个爱好，最终你意识到这可能是你想做的事情，
It's super intimidating. And every day before I've lectured, for the past 10 years, I have a moment in the hallway before I walk into my classroom. And I really do think about all of the experiences I've had presenting information to people that harken back to my 4-8 days in Bremer County, Iowa. And it wasn't my purpose when presenting about soil, which I got that red ribbon, by the way, because I called it dirt and not soil. That's why lessons learned.
这非常具有威慑力。在过去的十年里，在我每次去讲课之前的每一天，在走进教室之前，我都会在走廊里停留一会儿。我真的会想起我向人们介绍信息的所有经历，这些经历可以追溯到我在衣阿华州布雷默县参加4-H的日子。当我介绍土壤时，我的目的并不是——顺便说一句，我拿了红丝带，因为我把土叫做dirt而不是soil。这就是为什么会有吸取的教训。
It wasn't my purpose to end up as a professor. But I did have a sense of directionality, and I did have a sense that the lessons I was learning and the experiences I was having and collecting over time would bowed well for me in the end. And so far, that's been true. You know, one of the things you said a second ago about these three pathways to purpose, you're pursuing a hobby and eventually you realize this might be something you want to do,
我最终成为一名教授并不是我的初衷。但我确实有一种方向感，我确实有一种感觉，随着时间的推移，我正在学习的教训、正在经历和收集的经验最终会对我产生良好的影响。到目前为止，事实的确如此。你知道，刚才你谈到通往目标的这三种途径时说的一件事是，你追求一种爱好，最终你意识到这可能是你想做的事情，
or you're reacting to something that happens in your life, or you have a role model who has a sense of purpose and in some ways you're, you know, almost through all smoses, you're basically acquiring a feeling of what it's like to be animated by a sense of purpose. What strikes me about all those three pathways is that they do not involve someone sitting down on a couch and ruminating about what their purpose is. It's not sort of a mental process
或者你对生活中发生的事情做出反应，或者你有一个有目标感的榜样，在某些方面，你差不多是通过潜移默化，基本上获得了一种被目标感所激发的感觉。关于这三种途径，让我印象深刻的是，它们并不涉及某个人坐在沙发上沉思自己的目标是什么。这并不是一种心理过程
that basically asks the question over and over to yourself, what should I be doing, what is my purpose? It's actually much more active, it's actually engaged with the world I'm wondering if you can tell me about a project that you're involved in called grip tape that is also Similarly engaged with you know not just thinking about the development of purpose But how you actually go about it you work with you that ask them what they actually want to do and in some ways puts Caffleding under them. Tell me about grip tape and its connections
它基本上是在不断地问自己，我应该做什么，我的目标是什么？它实际上要积极得多，它实际上与世界息息相关。我想知道你是否能告诉我一个你参与的项目，叫做Grip Tape，它同样与你有关，不仅仅是思考目标的培养，还有你实际上是如何去做的。你和年轻人合作，问他们真正想做什么，并在某种程度上为他们提供支持。跟我讲讲Grip Tape以及它与你所了解的目标之间的联系。
with what you have learned about purpose. Grip tape is a wonderful program for young people to guide their own learning. The grip tape experience begins by asking young people, what is it that you want to learn? This can range from things like building bicycles. It can be, I wanna learn how to code. I wanna start a business.
Grip Tape是一个非常棒的项目，旨在指导年轻人自主学习。Grip Tape的体验始于向年轻人提问：你到底想学什么？这可以是从建造自行车之类的事情开始。也可以是“我想学习如何编写代码。我想创业”。
It doesn't matter, the content. And for 10 weeks, they engage in a learning challenge in which they go out into the world and gain the information that they need in the spirit of what they want to learn. Now, a couple of features about this is when you are selected into the Gryptate program is you're given a champion, an adult champion who's going to learn along with you. And the beauty of the program is these champions cannot have an expertise in the thing that the young person wants to learn. We typically think of mentors and champions as people who do have an expertise, but that
内容并不重要。在10周的时间里，他们参与了一项学习挑战，本着他们想要学习的精神，他们走向世界并获取所需的信息。现在，关于这一点的一个特点是，当你被选中加入Grip Tape项目时，你会得到一个冠军，一个将与你一起学习的成年冠军。这个项目的精妙之处在于，这些冠军不能在年轻人想要学习的事情上拥有专业知识。我们通常认为导师和冠军是那些确实拥有专业知识的人，但那
severely restricts the number of people who can serve as a champion by not having an expertise. Grip tape, what they've done, is invited young people to learn with a captive audience. There's an adult who checks in with them routinely and asks, what do we learn this week? What did you do? And you're sharing that information out. And a group of collaborators and I are partnering with the GRIPTAPE program to study this process. How does directing your own learning help young people cultivate a sense of purpose in life, curiosity, contribution, and well-being? The GRIPTAPE program challenges the idea that seeking purpose is only for the wealthy
通过不具备专业知识，严重限制了可以担任冠军的人数。Grip Tape所做的是邀请年轻人与忠实听众一起学习。有一个成年人会定期与他们核对并询问，我们这周学到了什么？你做了什么？你正在分享这些信息。我和一群合作者正在与Grip Tape项目合作研究这个过程。自主学习如何帮助年轻人培养生活中的目标感、好奇心、奉献精神和幸福感？Grip Tape项目挑战了这样一种观点，即寻求目标仅仅是为了富人
and well-connected, for students at Ivy League schools. It suggests that cultivating a sense of purpose is even more important for people who lack opportunities. Tony is a fan of the rapper Kendrick Lamar and his song Good Kid. It's about growing up in tough circumstances and finding your options are limited. I'm a huge Kendrick Lamar fan, shout out to Kendrick.
以及人脉广阔的人，为了常春藤盟校的学生。这表明，对于缺乏机会的人来说，培养目标感甚至更加重要。托尼是说唱歌手肯德里克·拉马尔及其歌曲《好孩子》的粉丝。这首歌讲述了在艰难环境中成长并发现自己选择有限的故事。我是肯德里克·拉马尔的超级粉丝，向肯德里克致敬。
This song is brilliant. It's an invitation to consider what it's like to be a young person growing up in a space where the options to cultivate your purpose are especially limited. a better person, I know you're hurt, isn't probably inferior, but what am I supposed to do when the bling and a red and blue flash from the top of your roof and your dog has to say roof and red. And what real choices does that allow this young person? So when people like me are hanging around saying, hey, let's cultivate purpose, right? Well, we have to be mindful that some individuals are living in spaces or find themselves in
这首歌非常出色。它是一个邀请，让我们思考作为一个年轻人在一个空间里成长是什么感觉，在这个空间里，培养你目标的选特别有限。更好的人，我知道你受伤了，可能并不逊色，但当你的屋顶顶部闪烁着耀眼的光芒以及红蓝两色的光，你的狗不得不说汪汪和红色时，我该怎么做？这给这个年轻人留下了什么真正的选择？所以，当像我这样的人到处说，嘿，让我们培养目标吧，对吧？嗯，我们必须记住，有些个人生活在空间里或发现自己处于
spaces where the opportunities to really think through the menu of possible selves may be quite constrained. I think it's just a keen reminder that we all are implicated in everybody else's environment. We all play a role in other people's purpose development. moment. Tony also cites the astronaut, May Jemisin. In a speech at the University of Virginia, May Jemisin talked about why humans dream about the stars, even when their own lives are besieged by everyday problems. In this clip, she cited a question posed to a scientist who was helping to build a telescope in South Africa.
在这个空间里，认真思考可能的自我菜单的机会可能非常有限。我认为这只是一个敏锐的提醒，我们所有人都卷入了其他所有人的环境中。我们在其他人目标的发展中都发挥着作用。此刻。托尼还提到了宇航员麦·杰米森。在弗吉尼亚大学的一次演讲中，麦·杰米森谈到了为什么人类会梦想星空，即使他们自己的生活被日常问题所困扰。在这段视频中，她引用了一位正在南非帮助建造望远镜的科学家提出的问题。
That people asked him, why would South Africa do that when it has issues and problems in poverty? He said, because people have dreams. And dreams don't all revolve around just food. He said, even a person sleeping on a floor in a mud hut without a blanket, dreams of things bigger than they are. And that our dreams are our hopes, that's where we move. So, Dr. Mae Jemisin, the first black woman in space,
人们问他，南非在有各种问题和贫困的情况下，为什么还要这样做？他说，因为人们有梦想。梦想并不完全围绕着食物。他说，甚至一个睡在泥屋地板上、连毯子都没有的人，也会梦想比他们自己更伟大的事物。我们的梦想就是我们的希望，这就是我们前进的方向。因此，麦·杰米森博士，第一位进入太空的黑人女性，
is a very inspirational person. And her aspiration, her purpose, is to travel to the nearest star and to really consider what it would take to do that. To say, what kinds of technologies should we get busy building, what kinds of activities, self-understandings are needed for us to build the kinds of technologies, the kinds of societies, the kinds of working group relationships that would allow us to successfully make this journey. We don't currently have the kinds of propulsion technology to get there, not in one piece
是一个非常鼓舞人心的人。她的愿望，她的目标是前往最近的恒星，并真正思考要做到这一点需要什么。去说，我们应该忙于建造什么样的技术，我们需要什么样的活动、自我理解来建造能够让我们成功完成这段旅程的技术、社会、工作群体关系。我们目前没有到达那里的那种推进技术，不是完整的一块
at least, but when you sit with her ideas, you realize that it's sort of a trick. It's really getting us to think about ourselves and what we need to do to work through our current challenges. But the genius of that articulated purpose is that it really invites us to think about all the things we need to do as individuals, as collective, as communities, from the arts to the sciences to survive that trip. And so it's a profound metaphor for purpose. from the arts to the sciences to survive that trip. And so it's a profound metaphor for purpose. It's sort of playing a trick on us to look inward. By talking about the nearest star and the journey
至少，但当你细细品味她的想法时，你会意识到这有点像个把戏。它真的让我们思考我们自己以及我们需要做什么来克服当前的挑战。这种明确目标的妙处在于，它确实邀请我们思考作为个人、作为集体、作为社区，从艺术到科学，为了在这次旅行中生存下来，我们需要做的一切。因此，它是目标的一个深刻隐喻。从艺术到科学，为了在这次旅行中生存下来。因此，它是目标的一个深刻隐喻。这有点像在对我们耍花招，让我们审视内心。通过谈论最近的恒星和旅程
that we should be preparing for, it's what we would do in the here and now that may be the most important part of that. Anthony Barrow is a psychologist at Cornell University. Along with Patrick Hale, he's the editor of the book, the ecology of purposeful living across the lifespan. Tony, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
我们应该做好准备，我们在此时此地所做的事情可能是其中最重要的一部分。安东尼·巴罗是康奈尔大学的心理学家。他与帕特里克·黑尔一起，是《跨越整个生命周期的有目的生活的生态学》一书的编辑。托尼，感谢你今天加入我们的《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。
Tony, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Joanna Weber. Joanna is a marketing executive and longtime friend
托尼，感谢你今天加入我们的《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯滕·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是乔安娜·韦伯。乔安娜是一位市场营销高管，也是老朋友
of the show. We recently had some questions about how to connect Hidden Brain to new audiences. Joanna hopped on a call with us while she was traveling and had great insights and advice. Thanks Joanna for your support and for your friendship. In the next episode of our Happiness 2.0 series, we ask which is better? Burst of euphoria or less intense but longer stretches of happiness? You might think of it as like two flavors of ice cream. You know, experiences are like gelato with this intense burst of happiness, but then it's gone. And then on the flip side, you know, material things are more like a big thing of froyo,
演出的一部分。我们最近有一些关于如何将《隐藏的大脑》连接到新受众的问题。乔安娜在旅行时给我们打了个电话，并提出了很好的见解和建议。感谢乔安娜对我们的支持和友谊。在我们《幸福2.0》系列的下一集中，我们问哪个更好？是一阵阵的 euphoric 狂喜，还是不那么强烈但持续时间更长的幸福？你可以把它想象成两种口味冰淇淋。你知道，经历就像冰淇淋一样，有着这种强烈的幸福感，但随后它就消失了。而在另一方面，你知道，物质的东西更像是一大罐冷冻酸奶，
where they're not like as amazing in any one moment, but like you can have it for a while. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. for a while. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在任何一个时刻，它们可能没有那么惊艳，但你可以享用一段时间。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。一段时间。这一集还没有评论。点击转录本中的任何句子即可发表评论。